no I do not and that is because I've
been trained up not to give away any
spoilers because my mother is always
trying to get them out of me she is yeah
she's become so sneaky with it she'll be
like Oh like how's work going are you
eating properly you do you kill thanos
how's it going everyone so last night
karen gillan who plays nebula in
guardians of the galaxy and Avengers
infinity war went on jimmy kimmel
and she said something during the
interview that made me stop and think is
this a little wink that she's giving to
Marvel fans of her confirming that there
is in fact time-travel and Avengers for
now there are a ton of theories going
around right now about Avengers 4 about
time-travel about no time-travel about
multiple realities about the events of
infinity war being in a time loop there
are just so many theories going on right
now and Marvel and Disney have just been
extremely secretive and quiet about
anything related to Avengers 4 where's
that trailer Disney and even though
nothing official has been confirmed I'm
pretty sure everyone believes that
there's going to be time travel involved
in some way but let's take a look at
what Karen Gillan said in her interview
on jimmy kimmel gosh I wish can you get
me in the next one it's called it's
already done right it's in the cache so
they're talking about Avengers for and
Jimmy Kimmel jokingly says can you get
me in the next one
and then he follows up with well it's
probably already done right because
they're done filming but Karen Gillan
just casually says we could probably
make it happen time travel don't
encourage this alright we're getting no
help from Flash Gordon now this could be
nothing but the way she says this is
just so casual she's sort of like yeah
we can make it happen you know time
travel no big deal just like we do in
the movie can and let's face it there's
going to be time travel in Avengers 4
you can't hide that from us Marvel I
mean an ant-man and the wasp there was
mention of a time
texe and one of the Infinity stones is
the time stone so at least in some form
it's happening and it seems like nebula
is going to be a part of it which makes
sense because she knows Santos better
than anybody that's alive right now and
in the comics she's actually the one to
wield the Infinity Gauntlet and undo
Thanos a snap so I think Karen Gillan
just confirmed that there is time-travel
in Avengers 4 whether she did it
intentionally or not okay but let me
know what you all think about what she
said in this interview also be picking a
giveaway winner in my next video coming
out today so this will be your last
chance to enter cash to enter for your
chance to win a copy of Infinity Ward
the art of the movie art book a copy of
infinity war Deadpool 2 or Ant Man and
the wasp on blu-ray and some special
edition posters all you have to do is
subscribe to my channel like this video
and comment down below with your
thoughts and your favorite superhero as
always thank you all so much for
watching
Wolf Wolf
[Music]
you